well it may be earth day but here at cbs
news we are celebrating earth 365.
humans involved in the fight against
climate change owe a huge debt of
gratitude to the oceans and the billions
of creatures that call them home water
absorbs most of our planet's heat but
marine life is key to keeping a lot of
our carbon out of the atmosphere without
this ocean ecosystem scientists say the
planet would have overheated already ben
tracy joined a science mission learning
more about the mysterious deep sea
creatures doing their part to protect
the planet
as the sun rises along the california
coast we head out into monterey bay with
researchers from the area's world famous
aquarium what are you guys doing out
here today what is the mission so we are
looking for deep sea animals and animals
that are really far from the surface but
also really far from the bottom
tommy knowles is the senior aquarist we
watched as the team deployed this
underwater robot to search for elusive
creatures in what's known as the
midwater of the deep sea compared to
some of the marine creatures we're all
familiar with the sharks the dolphins
those sorts of things how do these
compare so the animals that we're
looking for in the mid water
are a little bit more of the squishy
weirder looking animals
they are simply otherworldly floating in
the dark in what's known as the oxygen
minimum zone about three thousand feet
below the surface
the robot travels through so-called
marine snow mainly fish scales whale
poop and a lot of micro plastics from
humans
in these depths the researchers have
found this vampire squid
rare brightly colored jellyfish and also
this a barrel eye fish with a
transparent domed head revealing upward
facing eyes it's been seen by humans
less than 10 times it looks like outer
space down there and a lot of these
things look like aliens right well to be
honest they are the earthlings and we're
the aliens that are coming down with our
bright lights
to look in on them that is amazing
looking that red color they led us into
the ship's control room where they
remotely operate the underwater robot
it's really cool looking yeah it's
stunning just then they found this a
jellyfish so rare it doesn't even have a
name for now they just call it red x and
so now we wait for it to show up in the
collection tube number one they extend
the robot's arm and using suction
capture the creature in this container
yeah today we've had a few good hits so
hopefully that continues it did they
also collected this red paper lantern
jellyfish and another with a name that
would make dr seuss jealous the bloody
belly comb jelly
and he's in there
nice work
with the rover back on deck the team
rushes to transport their finds into
larger jars inside this makeshift lab
that is so cool
and it comes with it
wow
these underwater discoveries are now the
stars of a new exhibit at the monterey
bay aquarium called into the deep it
took nearly five years to design and
build this elaborate life support system
of pipes pumps and filters to replicate
the deep sea environment this exhibition
is the first one in the united states
and we think the world of this magnitude
beth redmond jones is in charge of the
aquarium's exhibits this is an
opportunity for visitors to see animals
that no one has ever seen before
but the science behind this display is
about much more than that we should
really call our planet ocean not earth
because two-thirds of the planets
covered by water
kelly benoit bird is the senior
scientist at the monterey bay aquarium
research institute or mbari how crucial
is the ocean when it comes to this
mitigation of climate change yeah the
ocean has taken up more than 90 percent
of the heat produced by global warming
and every year it sequesters about 25 of
the carbon dioxide that we emit into the
atmosphere from the burning of fossil
fuels so the ocean provides critical
life support
scientists are now studying the role
deep sea creatures play as millions of
them rise from the depths at night to
feed in the cover of darkness
this is the largest migration on the
planet every night at sunset they come
up to the surface and then they migrate
back down again at sunrise if you were
to make that move it'd be the equivalent
of a 10k to get your breakfast and then
another 10k before you went to bed i'm
far too lazy for that
me too
but what they're doing is no joke by
feeding on plants and marine animals
near the surface scientists now think
they might be responsible for
sequestering up to half of the carbon
dioxide absorbed by the ocean and that
provides a sort of biological conveyor
belt only when the carbon dioxide that's
taken up by plant life gets into the
deep sea does it stay there and stay out
of the atmosphere
of course that comes with a cost our
oceans are becoming more acidic and
rapidly warming that's making storms
stronger and more deadly
and could also impact the ocean life now
working overtime to protect our planet
so we're trying to understand exactly
how much of a role this migration plays
and what affects it
[Music]
but we already know enough to be
thankful to these amazing creatures that
dwell in the deep
for cbs mornings i'm ben tracy in
monterey bay california
amazing oh incredible incredible
out of sight no longer out of mind there
it is then tracy's got some great
assignments all the people he talks to
as well clearly love their jobs yes it's
like an advertisement for science and
earth education well and you hope that
maybe it inspires other people to take a
look at what they're doing i'm sure it
will and save the planet yeah that's the
bottom
check that one off let's keep it